Nancy Cordes is inside the US Capitol
where the president is set to deliver
tonight's speech Nancy good morning
these are about substance but it's also
we're judgment that many are judged
sorted by the style with which this
whole thing is carried out and
something's going to look different this
year a woman will be seated right behind
the president Nancy Pelosi tell us what
you're expecting tonight that's right
that symbol of divided government this
is gonna be the president's first State
of the Union before a house led by
Democrats are gonna be a lot more
Democrats out there in the audience than
there were when he gave this speech a
year ago so a lot more people sitting on
their hands and he says that he's going
to strike a note of unity tonight and
for all the pomp and circumstance he
knows that the rest of the week
Democrats are devoting to launching a
host of investigations into him into his
administration they're gonna be looking
at his tax returns looking at the child
separation policy other controversies so
yes there there will be some
glad-handing tonight and and you know
people showing their respect but it's
not gonna last very long we just did a
piece about the invited guests for the
White House and the Congress are you
reading into anything you reading
anything into that on either side oh yes
both sides definitely trying to send a
message just look who's going to be in
the first lady's box tonight Gail she
has invited a family members of an
elderly couple that was killed allegedly
by an undocumented immigrant clearly
that meant to send a message she's also
invited a six-year-old boy who has been
bullied we know that bullying is one of
her signature issues and the first
prisoner released by the first-step act
a criminal justice reform bill that was
supported by a lot of folks from both
parties so a bipartisan note there
Democrats on the other hand many of them
inviting government workers who were
affected by the government shutdown
either furloughed or went without pay
for five weeks air traffic controllers
and the like sending a not-so-subtle
message that they think that the first
shutdown was damaging and urging the
president not to allow another one to
happen in ten days and we could see
another one happen if the deal is not
put together Nancy before the 15th any
any signs that that could happen well
you know they're they're making progress
and if it was just up to these 17
lawmakers this really wouldn't be a
problem there's a lot of bipartisan
agreement when it comes to border
security measures and these are
appropriators they do this for a living
find agreements to fund the government
but the problem here is that what they
have - what they come up with has to
pass muster with the President and no
one is quite sure what he will accept so
that is a real wild card all right Nancy
thank you very much
thank you you're welcome